i want to take a couple of minutes
and uh
just talk about what's going on in
ottawa here and in in canada this will
this will take just a couple chris is
amen to the truckers it's been an
amazing week to witness and feel a sense
of unity and hope in this country again
that's something that's been missing
here for
almost three years now is
people don't see the light at the end of
the tunnel and they're pissed off
and there's a lot of people they're
saying upwards of a hundred and fifty
thousand now up in ottawa a lot of them
were uh truckers that started the
movement
uh to end the mandates and um you know
what does uh captain trudeau do he uh
says he has covet and he goes and hides
out not dealing with any of it oh and on
top of that he's virtue signaling a
bunch of nonsense in between i want to
show you this uh quick little quilt clip
before we get started let's see if i can
add the stream
and if you guys want to follow what's
going on a good resource i found here is
freedom.convoy2022
on instagram
i'm just gonna hit this and play it you
guys should be able to hear it if the
audio is no good let me know and i'll
turn it up a little bit but it's just a
two minute clip
the
small fringe minority
[Music]
minority that is here today what do you
think about that
[Music]
it's a pretty small fringe minority that
i'm looking at right now isn't it
it's very evident that this is not a
french minority i think there's about a
hundred thousand people here um like the
people i've spoken
do you find that there's a friendship
minority well
i'm happy to be part of this minority if
that's what you want to call it this is
amazing yeah i know i think the
government is now the fringe minority
definitely i don't think it is i think
those numbers are super represented and
misrepresented i think i talk to a lot
of people who feel like i do
and the math doesn't make sense it
doesn't add up well i can't say i'm
surprised when you see in the news that
it's just some fringe minority you can
basically tell right away that it's the
exact opposite of that and that's what's
happened here today and there's people
coming from every part of canada people
coming from all over the world and
i think we want to show these
politicians that democracy's back and
the canadians are waking up again
and uh my question was actually
just don't you know that say that is a
french minority that is here today um do
you really think that is a french
minority i think the politicians of the
french minority i think trudeau is a
fringe minority they you know it's not
they have a minority government so it
has minority right in it and we're only
given so many choices i don't think
anyone actually supports any of the
politicians in canada but when we have a
system of power imposed on us that gives
us basically two and a half choices that
are all exactly the same what are we
going to do we you know we're this is
what we're going to do we're going to
take back our freedoms we're going to be
the people democracy comes from the
greek deimos gracia literally means rule
of the people and that's what we're
doing
and uh do you think the mainstream media
are telling the truth i don't think the
mainstream media know how to tell the
truth even when they say a fact that
happens to coincide with reality it's
completely contextualized to be alive so
no they're incapable of telling the
truth and that's totally by design we
live in a corporate capitalist society
and every aspect of our society is
totally commodified how long do you
think the drug driver will stay here the
truck drivers will stay here as long as
they need to they are heroes right now
they're representing canadians we're
here supporting them we're going to be
here as long as we need to we're going
to support the truck drivers and the
truck drivers are going to stay here
until
those people realize that they aren't in
charge we are
thank you merci
that's it
that's what's going on man that's what's
going on
freaking clown world
we you know we're at this point
i heard denmark lifted all mandates
today
uh england left admin mandates over a
week ago the world's opening up like
it's time
you know we're basically dealing with
what's you know remnants of what's
become a common cold um
but
he's still fighting it man he's still
fighting it's such a weird thing
you